[Music]
foreign
I don't know what you're expecting now
that you're back I'm respecting adequate
compensation
Tulsa what's Tulsa I want you to go
there the horse races springboard mile
there's nobody doing nothing you can do
whatever you want
not exactly the welcome I was expecting
[Music]
my name's Tyson welcome to Tulsa two
grand a week you drive from me now
what crew runs this neighborhood no crew
up in here but in the middle of nowhere
what would it be I assume you don't have
chiante you assume correctly
[Music]
I wouldn't have pegged you if it's the
Boy Scout why not
this wasn't necessary
what is that place it's a dispensary
oh he's taking a break
this is how it's going to work I'll
protect you from The Gangs what gangs
and the law this is legal you got to
know your risk
there was no risk until you came along
ever heard of black McAdam it's a
motorcycle gang
they're overplaying around when I play
my hair you won't see it coming
any flammable liquids or firearms
in the Box
this situation is not going to be
controllable for much longer
let's go
we got a pretty good appetite for
someone who was just shot at I stopped
eating every time somebody tried to hurt
me I'd be a skeleton
I want to be upfront with you
if you get hungry because they were in
the market
nah there's no such a thing there's a
one-off
or one of many
too soon to tell
thank you